[Music]
it's not as if she were
a maniac
a raving thing
she just goes
a little mad sometimes
we all go a little mad sometimes
hello and welcome to another exciting
episode of rt essentials i'm nikki novak
and we're looking back at some of the
very best
most vital important and if i'm being
very honest here
groundbreaking films of all time of
course i could be talking about nothing
other than horse movies
[Music]
from black beauty to my friend flicka to
huh
hold on a second
oh
okay this episode now contains a
shocking twist that is right there will
be
no horses it's horror not horses ha i
got ya
i could be the next i have night
shyamalan
anyways today we're looking back on the
most essential horror movie twist of all
time that is right these are the spooky
films that manage to completely up in
audience expectations and we're gonna
walk you through all of these thrilling
and suspenseful reveals right from the
safety of wherever you're watching this
right now hopefully not in a secluded
house hopefully it's not haunted that
would probably be a little bit intense
for this episode you're gonna just need
to focus on those creaking floorboards
i'm here
and obviously we're gonna have to slap
this episode with the largest spoiler
warning stamp we could possibly ever
give you because we're basically going
to ruin a huge part of these movies
plots if you haven't seen them
[Music]
something
something in the mist cook john lee and
catch your breath something to miss took
john lee you know i could hear him
screaming
shut the doors shut the doors my god get
in the room the mist thomas jane stars
as artist david drayton who takes his
eight-year-old son billy to the
supermarket just after a severe
thunderstorm as a thick mist spreads
around their main hometown the problem
is wouldn't you know it contains
horrible creatures that like to eat
people prompting david little billy and
a whole bunch of other folks to hole up
in the market and hide for dear life
okay
all the way down
my run
now in the original story david escapes
with his son and a few other survivors
but they're unable to get back home so
they try to drive to hartford to stay
ahead of the killer mist and that's how
it ends
in darabont's twisted film conclusion
however david and his fellow survivors
agree to commit suicide together rather
than succumb to the monsters
but just after he shoots everyone in the
car even little billy he runs out of
bullets only then does he see the us
army in the process of exterminating the
creatures and restoring civilization
meaning that his friends and son would
have survived if he'd only waited
just a few more minutes it is so
agonizing 2007's the miss was actually
the third stephen king adaptation from
writer director frank darabont but the
first time he'd taken on one of the
author's straight up horror stories
believe it or not darabont had another
concept for the ending that would twist
the knife or thicken the fog even
further
post-suicide pact david would have also
seen a passing truck hearing most of the
other people who had stayed at the
supermarket
meaning that if he had simply remained
there instead of going out on his own
his son would have also survived
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
darabon only came up with this ending
after sending most of the cast home
rather than bringing them back to
louisiana to shoot new footage and went
with his original still super bleak
version author stephen king who's not
always a fan of other interpretations of
his stories nonetheless praised
darabont's new conclusion for the mist
which he called frightening and said it
gave him a jolt well if you can jolt
stephen king that's definitely a sign
that you
my sir are on the right track
hi sweetie hi
look who's here
hello max
my name is esther
she's been practicing the hallway
orphan
the story center centers on a couple
kate and john played by vera farmiga and
peter sarsgaard respectively
following a family tragedy they adopt
esther a nine-year-old russian girl from
a local orphanage but she soon starts
exhibiting
some strange and even violent behavior
it's not long before kate begins
suspecting that esther may actually be
evil though john assures her she's just
being paranoid she's a kid that's what
kids do
but ultimately it turns out that kate
was 100 totally right all along about
the evil thing grace
my god stop stop stop just stop talking
and go upstairs go to your room stop
talking to me like i'm a child i'm
calling sister judah tomorrow we're
gonna have a conversation about your
future in this house because i can't do
it i just i can't do it anymore esther
is actually a 33 year old woman named
lena commer from estonia who suffers
from a rare hormonal disorder that
stunts her growth and makes her appear
childlike and small she has spent her
life posing as a little girl in order to
get away with the murders the film ends
with kate killing lena sending her dead
body to the bottom
of an icy pond
the phone was actually inspired this is
the biggest plot twist you guys it was
inspired by a real news item from may
2007
an actual 34 year old woman named
barbara skrilova and posed as an orphan
in the czech republic
going somewhere kate
what are you doing here
she's fine
let's not make it
go to your room
honestly
we're past that now aren't we
i know what you're doing
i will not let you hurt my children
actress isabelle fuhrman was only 12
when orphan came out though she will
reprise her role of esther now in her
20s for the prequel orphan first kill
what did i tell you about sitting on the
floor but it's clean it makes no
difference why can't you ever choose
[Music]
the others nicole kidman stars as grace
stewart who moves with her two children
into a remote country house why are
these people always moving into remote
country houses stop it
anyway it was on the channel island of
jersey in the immediate aftermath of
world war ii now the kids suffer from a
physical sensitivity to light requiring
grace and her trio of new servants to
keep a close and protective watch over
them
over time grace begins to hear strange
noises and sensing a dark and intrusive
presence in her home
she comes to believe it's haunted by
ghosts who think that the house belongs
to them now here is the shocking twist
grace and her kids and the servants are
themselves the darn ghosts
during the war
it seems grace killed her kids and
committed suicide but now her spirit
just can't accept what she's done the
strange noises she's hearing are the
living people who have moved into the
house and they're actually trying to
expel her from the family but they don't
succeed
where
[Music]
[Music]
they're everywhere they say this house
is theirs the film concludes with grace
deciding the house is hers and she will
not tolerate any new occupants
the 2001 revisionist haunted house flick
the others came to be because tom cruise
doug writer director alejandro and
menobar's previous film aubry las ojos
aka open your eyes
not to be mistaken with eyes wide shut
cruz and cameron crowe bought the rights
to open your eyes and did a us remake of
vanilla sky penelope cruz plays the same
part in both movies
[Music]
[Applause]
on top of yourself though it was
produced in english most of the film was
nonetheless shot in spain the house used
for the shoot is the palazio de los
ornios in cantabria which was designed
in 1904 by a london-based architect for
the duke of san tomorrow it's one of the
few examples of victorian architecture
in spain
[Applause]
a tale of two sisters the film story
centers on a teenage girl sumi who's
released from a mental institution and
returns home to her family's secluded
estate along with her father protective
younger sister and stepmother she has
dreams about her late mother and comes
to suspect that her stepmother who was
her mother's former nurse may have been
responsible for her death she also sees
her stepmother tormenting and abusing
her younger sister
but of course as has become a little bit
obvious from many of the films on this
list things are not exactly always as
they seem especially in remote and
secluded estates i'm saying stop going
to them people
sue sumi and her father
actually
have been alone in the house the entire
time initially it seems as if she's just
been having elaborate delusions brought
about as a result of her dissociative
identity disorder and though that would
appear to be a pretty good explanation
there's actually a second
an even more shocking turn the vision of
sumi's younger sister and mother were
not delusions but spirits sumi was
actually seeing their ghosts who
returned to take revenge on her very
real and actual quite evil stepmother
though if you pay close attention
a tale of two sisters gives the jarn
game away a few times before the actual
twist is revealed in the very first
scene of the movie in fact sumi's doctor
shows her a photograph and asks her
which person in it she thinks she is
this is such a huge clue that she has
trouble distinguishing between her
personas 2003's a tale of two sisters
was a landmark on a number of levels it
was one of the very first korean films
to get a theatrical release in the us
and along with old boy also in 2003 the
movie helped to introduce american
audiences to the booming korean film
industry it remains the highest grossing
south korean horror film of all time i'm
really not that interested in it
come on man just one more double or
nothing
enough enough
what are you scared april fool's day
april fool's day is a horror comedy at
heart it follows a group of college
friends who spend the weekend leading up
to april fool's day their spring break
at the island mansion of socialite muffy
st john
muffy has set up various pranks around
the mansion which start out innocent
enough but eventually become a little
bit scary and a little bit violent
before long it's discovered that muffy
has actually a violently insane twin
sister
buffy
i can't make this up i mean she's been
slaying vampires and dealing with a hell
mouth so i would drive anybody to the
edge seriously
[Music]
as it turns out though in a decidedly
non-horror movie turn
no one has been hurt or killed there is
no puppy
and muffy is just playing an elaborate
trick on everybody she's just hoping to
turn the mansion into a resort for stage
horror events kind of a pro to escape
room and use this weekend as a test run
she is my queen great idea muff she even
had hollywood effects votes helping her
pull it off at the very conclusion it
seems momentarily like one of the
party-goers confused and not knowing
about the prank suddenly shows up to
kill muffy but no this too is just a
trick and everybody's totally fine
[Music]
the slasher genre had completely blown
up by the mid-1980s and was so popular
there were even a number of sub genres
april fool's day was one of a number of
80s slashers based around holidays or
special events the filmmakers originally
planned a darker ending that would have
revealed a non-prank
real plot by muffy's cousin to kill her
and claim the mansion for herself
dude it wasn't that good a business idea
not worth murdering over honestly this
was actually shot but paramount
executives felt it was too dark and
preferred the sillier it was all a gag
version so any real murders or attempted
murders were cut out of the film
the very last shot of a winking
jack-in-the-box was filmed as a
compromise
months after the original shooted rap
because the producer frank mancuso felt
that the new cut lacked a strong closing
beat
director henry george clouseau made a
number of important thrillers in crime
films over the course of his career
leading to frequent comparisons to the
great alfred hitchcock perhaps his best
remembered film is 1955's ley diabolique
based on the book she who was no more by
pierre buello and thomas narcissac
set at a boarding school in paris run by
the tyrannical and abusive michelle his
wife christina and her friend nicole
who's also a teacher at the school
feel pushed to the very edge by the
cruel michelle
so what do they do they drown him in a
bathtub and then dump his body in a
neglecting swimming pool the problems
arise when the body actually continually
disappears and christina and nicole
start hearing stories from people who
claim to have seen michelle around town
on one occasion christina returns to her
home to find
michelle's body in the bathtub
when he appears to wake up and come
after her she has a heart attack from
shock and dies
the film then reveals that michelle and
nicole had actually set christina up
from the very beginning they faked
michelle's murder and then proceeded to
torment his wife knowing that she was in
frail health and her weak heart would
fail if she suffered a great shock
they would have gotten away with it too
if a private detective who was
investigating the case didn't happen to
overhear them discussing their plot and
turn them over to the authorities
in a final twist a local boy indicates
that he's seen christina around town
even after her supposed death
[Music]
hold on guys is she a ghost now is there
an even deeper level of deception
happening here
well guess what we never even found out
so i'm sorry to even raise the question
the first place i don't have an answer
for you
[Applause]
knight of the living dead romero's film
codified a lot of these modern notions
of what makes a zombie in this film
there are reanimated corpses that
shuffle around and walk slowly and
desire to eat only human flesh
stop it you're ignorant they're coming
for you barbara
stop it you're acting like a child
they're coming for you
look there comes one of them now the
movie opens with siblings barbara and
johnny visiting their father's grave
only to discover that dead bodies seem
to be waking up and attacking people
banding together with the common
resourceful trucker ben and a few other
survivors in the area they hear radio
and tv reports about a zombie outbreak
spreading across the eastern coast of
the us
scientists believe it may be due to
radiation from a space probe sent from
earth to venus
[Music]
eventually everyone dies except ben who
survives a long zombie-filled night in a
cellar and emerges in the morning as an
armed posse takes out a number of ghouls
in the area
unfortunately they suspect ben is a
zombie himself and they shoot him the
movie ends with his body burning atop a
pile of corpses now contrary to what you
might have heard george a romero's 1968
classic knight of the living dead did
not invent the zombie horror genre in
fact the word zombie isn't even used
during the movie these monsters are
called ghouls at the time romero made
the film the american cultural idea
about zombies was more directly related
to haitian voodoo practices and earlier
zombie movies featured very different
kinds of monsters than what we think of
as today's modern walking dead
oh
[Laughter]
saw was the first screenplay written by
australian lee wannel who conceived of
the story along with his film school pal
james juan this of course is the same
duo that would later give the world both
the conjuring and insidious franchises
not to mention creepy puppet movie dead
silence and a very memorable jason momoa
slo-mo in aquaman the film as it
actually stands is set almost entirely
in a very dirty looking abandoned
industrial washroom that's where
photographer adam stanheit who's played
in the film by winnell
wakes up chained to a pipe opposite
oncologist dr lawrence gordon
[Music]
he's played by the dread pirate roberts
i mean
curiel was between them lies an apparent
suicide victim holding a gun and a
cassette recorder by listening to the
tapes they learn that they have been
taken prisoner by the jigsaw killer who
subjects his victims to twisted and
violent games that test their will to
survive
dr gordon ultimately does survive
by sawing off his own foot but just one
i mean he does get to keep the other
adam however sticks around long enough
to discover that the dead body on the
ground
is not actually a dead body but dr
gordon's former cancer patient john
kramer the jigsaw killer himself he gets
up and seals adam into the washroom to
die
i mean all is fair you lost the game you
gotta have rules somewhere we're just
totally living in anarchy right
gate of that chain
is in the bathtub
though the film in the franchise it
spawned eventually became synonymous
with gory violence and so-called torture
porn when el and juan originally felt
that the twist would be the major
selling point actor tobin bell who plays
the jigsaw killer also said he agreed to
make the film because he didn't even see
the twist coming when he read the script
and he thought it'd be working on the
whole project just for the final big
reveal the original movie still did
receive an nc 17 from the mpaa for its
extreme violence
one scene in which a man struggles to
pull himself through barbed wire was
shortened as was a scene with a woman
digging through a man's
intestines they're actually just pig
intestines come on we're on a budget
here
[Music]
psycho
the story concerns troubled motel owner
norman bates played in a classic and
career defining turn by anthony perkins
he's hounded by his domineering mother
with whom he lives in a big house
overlooking the property
real estate secretary marion crane is
murdered in the shower while staying at
the bates motel after having stolen a 40
000 cash payment from her employers in
phoenix and taking off
[Applause]
norman heiser belongings including the
money in her car and sinks it into a
nearby swamp he then must deal with
marion's sister her boyfriend sam and a
private detective arbogast who all show
up looking for the now missing woman and
cash
after norman kills arbogast lilah and
sam discovered the mummified corpse of
norman's mother in the house's fruit
cellar it turns out norman believing
himself now to actually be his jealous
and possessive mother committed the
crimes himself
the film ends with him in jail while
marion's car is retrieved by authorities
i'm not even going to sweat that fly
i hope they are watching they'll see
they'll see and they'll know and they'll
say
why she wouldn't even harm a fly cycle
was a radical change of pace for
hitchcock who had just before made the
globetrotting espionage adventure north
by northwest by comparison this new film
was made with a lower budget in black
and white with the aid of the tv crew he
used for his show alfred hitchcock
presents
it also became his most commercially
successful film of all time bringing in
32 million dollars at the north american
box office from a budget
of just 807 thousand dollars this marked
the fifth and final time hitch would be
nominated for best director though he
never won
sure yes he received an honorary irving
g falberg memorial award in 1968 but i
mean come on that is just crazy he never
won his oscar
iconic filmmaker alfred hitchcock paid
just nine thousand dollars for the
rights to author robert block's
1959 novel psycho after reading a
positive review of the book in the new
york times he was extremely secretive
about the project throughout his
development afraid that audiences would
find out some of the big twists before
the movie was released that included
purchasing the rights to the book
anonymously so the trades couldn't tip
people off to read it and find out what
happens he also refused to screen the
film at all even for press prior to its
release despite all of his best efforts
the hollywood reporter still ran a story
revealing the ending months before the
film came out but thankfully not that
many people read even in 1960. i know
that i've been a little distant
i know that it makes you mad i just
feel like i'm being given a second
chance and i don't want it to slip away
anna
happy anniversary
and
of course
drumroll please we close out with the
twist master general himself m night
shyamalan
contrary to popular opinion 1999's
sleeper smash the sixth sense was not
shyamalan's directorial debut
he made two previous films the 1992
indie drama praying with anger and the
1998 comedy drama wide awake
sixth sense however defined the concept
of an m night shyamalan film for the
remainder of his career he is still
coming up those darn twist endings not
to mention pulling
six oscar nominations including best
picture best director and original
screenplay and a cool 672.8
million dollars at the global box office
making it the second highest grossing
film of the year it was also
coincidentally released on shyamalan's
29th birthday
that must have been a party weekend a
total rager i really hope they danced
all night long and did the twist
she wanted me to tell you
she wanted me to tell you she saw you
dance
she said
when you were little you and her had a
fight
right before your dance recital bruce
willis stars as child psychologist
malcolm crowe
one year after being violently attacked
by a former patient in his home crow
returns to work and takes up the case of
a nine-year-old boy named cole
memorably played by young hayley joel
osmond the boy believes he sees ghosts
walking around everywhere he goes only
they don't know that they've died though
at first he believes that cole is simply
troubled
over time malcolm becomes convinced that
the boy is telling the truth and he
encourages him to try and communicate
with the spirits
of course the now infamous twist
is that malcolm was actually dead the
whole time i just gave myself chills
saying it he was killed by that former
patient in his home but needed to stay
behind and help another boy call before
he could move on to the afterlife don't
go home okay
i definitely won't
[Music]
well we used up our shocking twist in
the intro so
i'm afraid i don't have anything else
really free
hmm
wait hold on
oh
as it turns out
i've been dead this whole time
that's wild
i guess it's being left ambiguous
but here's what's not ambiguous you
should stay tuned to rotten tomatoes for
lots more essential info updates and
strolls down memory lane about all our
favorite movies of yesterday and today
see you next time
[Music]
you